today's leftist are nothing like the
Liberals of even ten years ago and
they've totally taken over the Democrat
Party they're calling all the shots no
one even bothers trying to stop them
Hannity just referenced that when
they're destroying private or public
property local and state authorities all
Democrats here they cower when the
Birkenstock Bolsheviks occupy huge
swaths of a city like Seattle have they
sent free vegan pizzas to all the angry
squatters yet I'm expecting that extra
pairs of skinny jeans foot rubs salt
scrubs wait by the way look at these
videos I thought they were against
borders there's nothing about this bunch
that's liberal because the old liberal
started the Free Speech Movement at
Berkeley in 1964 and it was devoted to
reversing the prohibition on political
activities on campus now don't get me
wrong they were radicals but at least
they actually believed in free
expression I think they generally liked
the country well not so with the
neo-marxist of today there
sledge-hammering statues and smearing
anyone who doesn't bow down open their
wallets or make a confessional on social
media these performance activists who've
marinated an anti Americanism online in
the classroom they don't believe in free
speech or freedom of worship or even
academic freedom for anyone who
disagrees with them they've never really
learned anything in depth and positive
about the Constitution
maybe besides that it was well they've
learned that it was agreed to and
written by a bunch of old dead white
guys thus history means nothing to these
folks free inquiry means nothing to them
they want trophies may be mounted on the
wall though heads of old Confederate
generals or pink slips for academics who
defy them a Cornell Law professor whose
website dared critique BLM is now under
siege from a mob of angry left-wingers
one student complained his articles were
quote hurtful and divisive the professor
is going to join us later in the hour
now last night a similar story out of
UCLA although a different culture crime
was alleged the professor in the
crosshairs Gordon Klein has taught
business classes there for 39 years and
he issued this stark warning to
Americans about the state of education
today in America I was easy to sacrifice
when they're weighing the principle of
standing on equality of treatment for
all students irrespective of color
versus trying to placate the angry mob
it is absolutely a sad day for free
inquiry a similar thing by the way is
playing out in University of Chicago as
well I just tweeted about it a few
minutes ago but this is a sustained
campaign of personal destruction that's
all it is the Marxists aren't interested
in debate they're not interested in
reconciliation they're certainly not
interested in compromise they aren't up
at night worrying about cultivating
peace or spreading prosperity to you
they care about power getting it and
keeping it they want total and complete
submission from any institutions where
they can gain leverage to advance their
goal of a full takeover of American life
and I'm talking every aspect of it
remember when Obama said you didn't
build that well today's radicals believe
the only reason you own property is
because you took it unfairly from
someone else or you got it by exercising
your white privilege and when you think
that every American is living on stolen
land as they do wicked and evil well why
shouldn't everything be burned down
why shouldn't its history be leveled if
it means they have to threaten companies
to get their money and cooperation
they'll do it if it means that they
target individuals through intimidation
they'll do it if it means using the
horrific death of someone like George
Floyd to market a vicious hatred of all
law enforcement they'll do it and they
did it the family of officer Shaye Mikal
lowness of Nevada knows just how serious
these neo-marxist are he was shot in the
head last week while work
the protests in Las Vegas doctors now
expect him to be on a ventilator for the
rest of his life he's only 29 defunding
the police will mean more violence fewer
officers to respond and more carnage the
real oppression and danger to our
communities comes more from violent
crime and lawlessness than it does from
the police that was Bill Barr today in
Dallas with the President did an amazing
panel and of course president Trump
upsets today's illiberal elites when he
tweets things like law and order very
short tweet
well he's not sensitive in enough they'd
say there has to be more sensitive well
on the contrary law in order is what all
of our citizens deserve that is being
sensitive not just the ones by the way
rich enough to afford personal private
protection if all police precincts are
overrun the populist conservatism of
Trump is dedicated to improving the
lives of all Americans blue-collar
low-income and entrepreneurs of all
backgrounds and all races and creeds
stopping the endless wars forcing China
to come to the bargaining table with
tariffs strengthening our borders
eliminating onerous regulations these
were all real actions that reaped huge
results until the covert shut down but
now for a moment
I imagine a u.s. led by President Joe
Biden who you know will just melt for
the macchiato Marxist imagine all the
old statues the monuments all those
offending flags are all gone all
politically incorrect songs and movies
pulled all workplaces all classrooms
will enforce speech codes police
departments will be defunded or
disbanded imagine all that's taken place
then what how does any of that create
jobs for the least among us for anybody
how does any of that raise wages how
does any of that make our neighborhoods
safer holla improve race relations
patronizing symbols or gestures might
feel good in the moment but they don't
end up putting food on the table or
paying your kids tuition bills a good
paying job does though it's obvious
right now that an alliance of media
political and radical forces are trying
to demoralize millions of law-abiding
Americans who believe in equality and
justice for all
and who also support President Trump
they want you to think that all hope is
lost they want you to think that
America's best days are over they want
to stop Trump's rallies and even use a
virus threat to keep you out of church
and separated from your family and
friends well tonight I say don't let
them don't give in to this campaign of
demoralisation these are some of the
most racially polarizing vindictive
people on the face of the planet and
they have no right to lecture you and no
right to take away your voice we do
substance they do symbolism they burn
stuff down we're building it up we're a
free people and we're going to stay that
way and that's the angle